(upbeat music)
- People ask me that
question all the time:
what is it feels like to get hit?
It's like a little explosion in your body,
if they hit you at the right spot.
But I'm not really trying to hurt them.
Actually, except when
I'm hitting the body,
I really like hearing people, like, grunt.
(suspenseful music)
There are very few female boxers that
are still in the game
that have that longevity
in the sport that I've had.
In 20 years of boxing, I've
never been knocked out,
much less knocked down and
I think the reason for that
is not just because I'm strong,
it's because I don't take punches.
I'm never there to get punched.
It's weird.
It's very hard for me to associate being
World Champion with my name.
I mean, I have an office that has my belt
and all these photos of all the
different titles that I've won,
but I just don't feel
like it applies to me.
(calm piano music)
I was dancer so only when I was injured
and knew that I couldn't dance anymore
that I took up something
else, just for exercise.
So went into kickboxing
and eventually into boxing.
Because I started out as a dancer,
one of the biggest elements that I bring
into my boxing is movement.
When I first came into boxing,
there were very few women
and the mentality of
the guys that were here
were that, "You shouldn't box."
"You're too pretty to box."
You know, ”Go back to dance or something else."
This is a sport like any other sport.
I can do it.
Any female can do it.
The best recognition I
had was when someone said,
"She fights like Pernell
Whitaker or Muhammad Ali."
They didn't say I fought like a female.
I'm 48 and for my next fight,
I'm gonna try to be the
oldest female title holder
and that would be in the
Guinness World Record,
so there's different
things that I need to win.
There's different things that I need to do
and World Champion is just one of it.
(upbeat melodic music)